they home of next year's first in the
nation presidential primary he said the
US should take one and a half trillion
dollars worth of Iraq's oil to pay for
the Iraq war he also wants to use the
money to give two million dollars each
family of a servicemen who died in
combat much it's a great honor to be
here and I have to tell you this is sort
of where it all started for me because
in 1989 a friend of mine a good friend
of mine said would you do me a favor and
come up to New Hampshire and make a
speech and I did it was really a speech
and success and a motivational type
speech get people working and the nice
part about New Hampshire everybody works
and we love workers and I think that's
why I like New Hampshire a lot of
workers but I made this speech and I
left and I came back to New York and I
heard I was running for president so
that was the first time I heard about
running for president for Donald Trump
and it was very interesting but i will
say that all of my life I've heard that
very successful people cannot run for
high office I just heard it so many
times and you know it was interesting
because nobody said it was going to be
easy but I had no idea I would get
hammered like I've been hammered over
the last three or four weeks it's
actually I think a compliment I'm not
sure I went as an example to the
Washington speaker's bureau were a
dinner in Washington and it was very
interesting the washington
correspondents dinner was packed with
people it was an amazing event actually
I'd been there before so I knew what I
was getting into it sort of the Lions
Den but the president got up and very
respectfully said things and he said a
lot about me and they were jokes he had
a picture of the White House with the
Trump on top of it and some other things
that it was very nice there was a
comedian that got up and he started
talking about me I looked at my wife I
said is this a good thing or a bad thing
am I supposed to be honored or am I
supposed to hide under the table I
wasn't exact so I so did just SAT there
and listened and took it in but it was
actually a little bit amazing and i will
say that it's been an amazing
period of time for me because I'm not a
professional politician which i think is
possibly an asset other than our great
mayor who is a great great leader right
but I think that's actually turned out
to be largely an asset according to a
lot of people and you know I I took on
the president I was very very strong and
saying put up your birth certificate I
was very strong on it now whether I was
right in doing that or wrong and doing
that I don't care I mean why not show it
and why did it take so long and I was
honored that I was able to get him to do
it and I guess he will continue and that
whole debate will rage and everything
else but my big thing and always has
been from day one has been jobs it's
been jobs it's been the economy I built
a great business a really great business
I built it over a period of years it's
doing unbelievably well in bad times
we've made a lot of good decisions a lot
of decisions that have been really
terrific and I love doing what I'm doing
I have to be honest I mean I hate
getting out of that business and doing
something else but our country is in
serious serious trouble like it's never
been before the kind of numbers we're
hearing today are so unbelievable
they're so incredible in size you know
three or four years ago you never heard
the word I don't know if you can agree
with me on this you never heard the word
trillion trillion and now everything's
trillion deficits debt budgets it's
trillion with trillions of dollars in
the hole and a lot of people don't see
how to get out of it and you know my
businesses can be good but my businesses
won't be good if this country is going
to be going down down down and it's got
a very big shot at doing that and I am a
very no tax person but I can tell you if
President Obama gets reelected I think
your taxes are going to go through the
roof and I do believe
that he's holding him down now as long
as he can because he wants to get
through this election but I said it
before I met with a great group of folks
and some of the real community leaders
and we had a very frank discussion and I
said look if he gets in office I believe
I honestly believe that your taxes are
going to go to a level that they haven't
been at in a long time and that's not
going to be good for this country that's
not going to be good for business it's
not going to be good for New Hampshire
it's going to be good for no one so we
have a real problem and the problem that
we also have is we don't use our best
people you know negotiation is an art
and I've seen it over many years I know
the guys in New York I know the good
ones I know the bad ones I can
practically tell you who does the good
deals who does the bad deals the fact is
it's an absolute art and we're not using
our right people as an example and I say
it all the time China this year's going
to make three hundred billion dollars
off of this country call it profit but
beyond that they're taking our jobs
because they're making our product so
they make our product they take our jobs
they do it through manipulation of their
currency very simply and then the
president of China comes to the United
States and we hold a beautiful evening
at the White House forum in other words
we honor a man that's taken advantage of
this country now I don't blame him
because if you can get away with it why
not do it so they then go out and buy
our debt and we pay them interest I mean
the whole thing is unbelievable you look
at what OPEC is doing to us these folks
sit around a table you probably saw last
week Saudi Arabia said oh there's a lot
of oil out there we're cutting
production so we're going to cut it back
and they cut back production because
they want to keep the prices high and we
don't have anybody that says that's not
going to happen folks that's not going
to happen you're not doing it anymore
you know we protect them they pay us
virtually nothing we protect so many
countries we protect South Korea I
ordered 4,000 television sets
last year for hotels and different
things and by the way I heard this
hotels in trouble I love things that are
in trouble that's what I like to buy I
love it thank you for telling me Chris
you're the broker Chris wherever you are
no I'm only kidding actually the food is
very good although i'm not kidding
actually am i i'm not kidding about that
anyway it's a nice hotel in fact i'm
going to take a tour of the hotel later
if you want to know that as opposed to
saying a load of political leaders i'm
going to tour the hotel i'm more used to
doing it but you look at what OPEC's
doing to this country and i always say
the worst of user of the United States
and the word abuse is the right word to
use is opec the second worst abuser is
China and then there are many countries
after that and as an example Columbia
the fourth largest country in Latin
America they made last year in the
United States four billion dollars this
isn't a huge country we don't even do
that much business with them they made
four billion dollars it's like what's
going on what are we doing and we're now
signing a new trade pact that I don't
think just in reviewing it is going to
be as good as the old one so you wonder
where does this thinking come from how
does it happen and then you look at the
deficits and I have to say I'm a very
proud Republican I'm very proud of our
ideals at least most of them and I look
at a plan that was put forward and I
like Paul Ryan very much but the plan
that was put forward was early there was
no reason to put a plan forward where
they're even talking about touching
Medicare at this point there's no reason
for it so Medicare and Medicaid all of a
sudden come in and it's put in by the
Republicans and you've got elections to
win the Republicans have elections to it
and the Democrats you talk about
demagogue the Democrats are doing a
number on that plan like I've never seen
so in upstate New York we lost a
congressman who decided to go on
whatever was
show what kind of a great body he had
you know all about that and he was
looking for people on the internet and
they caught him and they throw him out
he should be thrown out do we all agree
yes so a very popular Republican woman
is running for the office she was
expected to win easily Republican area
easy like crazy well the other day in
front page of a major newspaper there's
a story that you may not win because
she's having a hard time defending that
whole situation with Medicare now the
president I'm talking about negotiation
the art of the deal one of the great
business books of all time right
everybody run it you know it's funny it
is the biggest selling or at least one
but I think the biggest selling business
book of all time and every time I
mentioned people do a ploy they love
that book a lot of people tell me they
got their start by reading that book you
know whatever but call it the art of the
deal you got to let him go first he's
supposed to be the leader let him put up
a plan let him come in and put up the
plan and then you can use your debt
limits and you can use all sorts of
things to do what you have to do when
you look at what happened recently where
they thought it was going to be 38
billion and it was 300 million in
savings and the whole big thing there
are so many things going on and I'm just
saying what is happening what is
happening to this country we have a
chance to be great again and honestly
right now the way we're doing we're a
debtor nation and think of it I so
recently a report we are spending two
billion dollars so Brazil Brazil can
drill for oil why aren't we drilling for
oil why are we drilling for oil in this
country
a friend of mine who's doing pretty well
and not a real rich guy but a guy who
he's always wanted to do this he bought
an airplane or he's buying it and I said
oh what kind of a plane is he tells me
the name of the plane Oh where's it made
Brazil I said why in Brazil he said
because I get a 1.2 million dollar tax
credit than the United States if I buy
this play and I'm saying what is going
on so we don't use our right people now
I know Wall Street very well I know all
of the killer's I know all of the guys
that are the smartest guys i know the
ones that aren't as smart i know thought
of all of them and why aren't we when we
negotiate against China against South
Korea against all of these countries why
are we using our smartest greatest
business people who by the way I put
them against anybody we have the best
I'd put them against anybody but instead
we use a diplomat and as I've said a
diplomat you know what a diplomat is
that's a person that studies how to be
nice I don't want a nice person and
that's why I may not make it in terms of
getting I'm not that nice a person but
i'll tell you what i'd make this country
great again that i can tell you
now we had a great victory last week
with the killing of bin Laden that was
great an enhanced interrogation really
led us to that now enhanced
interrogation another thing you know
we're so politically correct and nobody
wants to say it nobody ever wants to use
the word isn't another word for that
torture and you know what the people
that i watch jump off the World Trade
Center that was torture ok so we catch
this guy they shoot him then they clean
his body they give him a religious
ceremony they take 45 minutes they tell
you why I don't understand it ok I don't
understand it and in terms of torture in
terms of enhanced interrogation we
wouldn't have caught in Laden without it
that's what got us to him and we're
right now as you know they're under
investigation numerous people that used
enhanced interrogation to use the nicer
term after September 11th and I think
those people should not be under the
kind of gun that they're under I don't
think so at all
now one of the things that was recently
found out is that bin Laden's plan and
one of his plans and he had many of them
was to bankrupt what was the former
Soviet Union which he succeeded in doing
and hence it broke up and now it's
called Russia smaller version very
powerful smaller version but that war
bankrupt 'add Russia he wanted he want
and he wanted to bankrupt the United
States now we're spending ten billion
dollars a month ten billion dollars on
building schools on all of the other
things that we're doing in Afghanistan
and for what what are we doing and I
heard something the other day that I
have to really we're going to do a
little research you're all going to do
this research while we're fighting in
Afghanistan I heard that they have
tremendous mineral resources in
Afghanistan I always thought you know I
look at the oil I look at Iraq I look at
the different countries and I see things
but tremendous mineral resources and you
know who's in there trying to get them
China while we're out there fighting
spending billions and billions and
billions of money nobody knows how much
money was spending nobody knows but
we're spending billions of dollars on
fighting Chinese out there trying to get
its foot to get the minerals in
Afghanistan I mean think of that but we
can't build schools in our own cities we
can't build roads in our own cities I've
been to China no where's times and I see
bridges going up and I see airports
going up like you wouldn't believe when
was the last time you saw a major bridge
being built in the United States doesn't
happen first of all you can't get the
environmental approvals it's impossible
you know when I was over there was very
interesting a friend of mine from China
hey I respect what they do if they can
take advantage of our leaders you know I
have great
for that if they can do it but they're
filling in a big chunk of the ocean and
I'm saying to myself huh I said to my
friend how long did it take you to get
your environmental permits he looked at
me goes what what are you talking he
said Donald it's the ocean you know
they're filling in about a quarter mile
by a quarter mile they're going to build
a big complex a huge thing and they
actually fill in parts of the ocean to
build the city you know that they build
new cities over there like in about 12
minutes they say we want a city over
there they start work the next day mayor
it's a little different than what we do
right but I know and I've gotten many
environmental Awards so I don't want to
sound like this guy that's oh gee I'm
totally into fairness but I've seen jobs
that were going to employ thousands and
thousands of people stopped because of a
blade of grass that happens to be a
unique blade of grass I've seen them
stopped over a certain type of fish over
this and that and I deal with
environmental consultants all the time
and I look at them and I say you know
that's horrible that's horrible I mean
they're gonna stop progress isn't that
horrible because actually Donald it's
not horrible for me because I'm making a
fortune and you're paying me a fortune
and so is everybody else and these guys
actually go up to Albany in the case of
New York and they make the restrictions
harder the consultants that are working
for you so that you have to hire them to
get you through this horrible situation
and in many cases you can't get through
and if you're not rich you can't get
through at all because you can't go
through the process I mean I could tell
you job after job after job and it's
like even the drilling of oil where Abu
Dhabi recently and they have so much
energy they have such resources they
went out and they announced that they
were going to have all of their
transportation needs done in guess okay
because they just they wanted natural
gas that's it because they're going to
sell the oil to the United States
in other places and yet we're the king
of natural gas we have more natural gas
than anybody coal natural gas I mean
wind is limited honestly solar really
hasn't been perfected and it's very
expensive I know them all you know I go
and I build a building and ice I want to
use solar I want to use solar and I'm
good at dollars so I look they come back
and the solar they said yes that will
take you approximately 22 years 22 year
payback I said that's not so good maybe
I won't use solar it hasn't been
perfected and it's going to get better
but we have tremendous with a king of
coal we're the the all-time of natural
gas we don't use it and then you hear a
country like Abu Dhabi using natural gas
so they can sell their oil and it's just
incredible to me I look at what's going
on I look at pakistan not our friend and
i have to say if you look at bill
o'reilly from a few weeks ago if you
look at neil cavuto from not so long ago
I said Osama bin Laden is in Pakistan
and some of you probably heard this and
I was very loud and clear we give
Pakistan billions and billions of
dollars a year we're going to give them
3.2 billion I think they're asking for
now and even more and I said listen I
understand something about that you tell
them that we're not giving them this is
on two shows a little while ago long
before the event took place last week
you tell them we're not giving you any
money unless you hand over to us Osama
bin Laden and have anybody looked at me
like man nobody else picked it up you
know it's amazing I make these
statements and no politician picks them
up so obviously they're not very good
statements i guess but they never get
picked up and you know when they are
good it's interesting because i have
another one but when they are good they
pick them up and they don't give me
credit that's what I hate about politics
Mary you know when I buy a piece of real
estate I own it okay
but you know when you come up with a
good idea in politics if they like it
they take it knitter you know they say I
have an idea you know by that time most
people forgot it was Trump's idea so
Trump doesn't get any credit and I love
to get credit I love I love to get her
on it but I said right on their
television you could look over the last
number of weeks those two shows let them
give us this guy now if anybody thinks
that they didn't know that he was there
when they have a sophisticated when
somebody said many times the size of
West Point that he wasn't sitting in
this big house I didn't think was
particularly beautiful but you know they
made it like this incredible mansion
does anybody in the audience want to
live in that Mitch I don't think so but
if anybody thinks that Pakistan that the
government didn't know that he was there
they're foolish ok they're very foolish
so they're not really our friend and
they're not really our enemy but now I
say differently and I think this is very
important because the bad guys could
take over Pakistan very easily very
quickly it could happen very quickly we
wouldn't even know what's going on they
have nuclear weapons they desperately
need our money we don't give them any
money unless they get rid of their
nuclear weapons now to me that's so
simple
so I hope it does get picked up by some
of the other people but for us to be
giving them money they go out and by the
way they take our money they use it for
nuclear they also use it for themselves
by the way I guarantee you that but they
go out and they use that money for
nuclear weapons and you know what let's
say right now they're semi friendly but
they may not be at all friendly they may
be tremendously against us including
Israel because if that happens Israel's
in big big trouble they have serious
nuclear weapons but they seriously need
our money and that's a deal that I would
make and I wouldn't I wouldn't veer from
it because you cannot let them have
those nuclear weapons another one I gave
that some people did pick up and some
people love it and some people think oh
but it's a sovereign nation Iraq we go
into Iraq we've spent 1.5 trillion
dollars we've lost thousands of great
young men and women we have tens of
thousands of people that are incredible
people that are horribly wounded with
legs and arms missing and just horribly
wounded all over the cities all over the
cities I see it in New York I see it all
over and we go in we fight and we leave
somebody said oh democracy give me a
break as soon as we leave Iran is going
to take over Iraq we've decapitated
their armies it's going to happen
they're already planning it I've heard
that they're closer to the leaders of a
rack then we are okay then our people
are and I'm not surprised to hear it
Iran is very cunning and very smart so
they say they've been fighting for years
and years you know for years they were
about equal they moved two feet they
move back to feed by the war's over they
go back and for 20 more years they don't
fight right and this fight again but now
what we've done is we've decapitated one
of those countries so Iran will go in
but here's what they're going to go in
for sure don't want the country sort of
what they really want is the oil you
know that Iraq
has the second largest oil reserves in
the world 15 trillion dollars
interestingly mayor that's very close to
our our deficit right isn't it
interesting amazing number so I've said
to people what is this you know maybe
I'm old-fashioned I say we're in there
and I have friends and they're really
good people and they're smart people and
there and there's some of them are very
liberal some are conservative but a lot
of them say Donald are you suggesting we
take the oil that's a sovereign nation I
say excuse me and it's amazing now some
people love it I would say they're the
smart ones because when we went into
Iraq if you remember when we went into
Iraq a lot of the so-called smart ones
were saying oh don't worry about we only
went in for the oil we didn't we weren't
smart we didn't know what we were doing
we went in what for what he did knock
down the World Trade Center in all
fairness you like Saddam Hussein you
don't like Sudan it doesn't make any
difference he did not knock down the
World Trade Center had nothing to do
with it and frankly what he did do is
kill terrorists you could not be a
terrorist in Iraq he would kill you no
trials no nothing he would kill you if
you were a terrorist now Iraq is the
Harvard of terrorism you want to be a
terrorist you go to Iraq everybody says
that you want to be a terrorist Iraq is
great Afghanistan's pretty good too
right below and I'm saying what are we
doing so we've got our army over there
then somebody said oh we don't want to
stay longer you know the kind of money
we're talking about so they have 15
trillion dollars worth of oil we've
spent 1.5 trillion I say this at a
minimum we get our money back and we pay
each one of the families of those
soldiers that died a couple of million
dollars and we give our badly wounded
and our wounded a lot of money its
peanuts you're talking about peanuts
compared to what the numbers are in this
incredible oil reserve
and we pay those families back now
people say to me you can't do that
because of the sovereignty of the nation
but let me ask you this when the
families of those fallen soldiers are
sitting home watching television in a
couple of years from now after we're
gone because they're not going to go
when we're there but you know we have an
appetite to get out then we're never
going to go back because we don't have
that stomach when the families of those
great soldiers are sitting home a couple
of years from now when I ran goes in and
takes over Iraq and takes over the oil
and tells everybody how stupid the
United States is which is absolutely
going to happen and they'd be right how
do you think the parents of that 22 year
old soldier how do you think the parents
are going to feel about that because
those soldiers will have died in vain
and again all of the wounded all of the
money what a terrible terrible situation
now just like I said cuz I've made a lot
of good predictions you know I had a
book and I made a lot of predictions in
the book and a lot of them came true i
said terrorism is going to happen i said
you can have a market crash I don't know
I'm not saying I'm a great psychic but I
have a good instinct for things and I
think most good business people do
that's why you know we're a little bit
ahead of the curve in a lot of ways but
I have an instinct for things and I said
terrorism's are going to be a big factor
and people sort of didn't know too much
about what terrorism was then because
that was 10 or 11 years ago I said we
could have a great crash and we really
did have a great crash that was a great
question we could have a second grade
crash if gasoline doesn't go down
substantially we've got to have a second
crash if oil stays at over a hundred
dollars which I think it's going to for
a while I could go a lot higher we could
have a real real problem and we could
have a real second dip as they call it
so I know how to deal with OPEC I know
how to deal with china by the way I had
some of the smartest Chinese I made a
deal with them I made a lot of money I'm
very proud of myself I made a lot of
money and got to know how to deal with
these people
they're smart they're cunning and they
are not our friends remember that they
are not our friends at all so I'm
thinking about running I must be honest
it's tough because I'm very anti
establishment that even includes the
Republicans you know like for instance I
told you I have great respect for Paul
Ryan but I would not have done it the
way he did it too early too soon there
was no reason for him to do it let the
other guy lead it in and then you go and
do your number and you get something
that's going to make the country great
again but I'm very anti establishment
and I see even the Republicans taking
show what's to take a shot at what
really now there'll be people on
television they'll say bad things about
me but what really that I said today can
people take a shot at I want to take
care of our fallen soldiers I want to
take care of our people I want the oil i
want reimbursement to us and by the way
to the other countries that helped us
like Britain and other countries I want
to take advantage of I really want to
take advantage of a situation where
there once we leave we can't but what
when you think about it what's
controversial so I go back and I'm a
Republican and I'm doing this you know I
haven't done anything at all fairness I
haven't even announced whether or not
i'm running and I think even the
Republicans don't like it because I'm
not in the club I'm not in that Club you
can't be in that Club and that Club is
not what's going to make us in my
opinion a great country again we have
tremendous potential tremendous
unbelievable potential if we had the
right people if we knew what we were
doing we cannot let China drain us we
cannot let OPEC drain us we cannot let
South Korea drain us when I ordered the
4,000 televisions I said find an
American company I want to find an
American company that makes them we have
the greatest people nobody could do it
they can't find a company yeah
had little companies that made a couple
that I need 4,000 televisions it's a lot
of televisions so we got LG from South
Korea that's interesting because you
know South Korea we have thousands of
soldiers in between north and south
korea and you know what happened we're
all set to sign this agreement and they
said no no we don't want it now Baron
Trump was my four-year-old son would not
have agreed to that agreement for the
United States that's how bad the
agreement is but South Korea it wasn't
good enough for them so they embarrassed
the president by not signing when they
were supposed to but a couple of days
later some bombs started getting lobbed
over to South Korea by North Korea and
we send this magnificent aircraft
carrier the George Washington like
incredible and 17 destroyers and boats
and like an armada boom just to turn on
the engines probably 2,000 bucks okay
two million dollars so we're sending
this big Armada over there costing a
fortune and North Korea said okay look
we don't want to miss her i will stop
we'll stop bombing them but south korea
said but we want to sign the agreement
it's a wonderful agreement for a URL
you're our great friend I mean how
stupid are we they wouldn't do it all of
a sudden as soon as the bombs got lofted
please send it over here we want to sign
it immediately who's going to notarize
the agreement for me okay so we have to
use her head south korea makes a fortune
of fortune selling us televisions and
lots of other things they have to pay us
a lot of money for protection has to pay
us we can't protect them what are we
protecting them for so they can make
money in the United States now
unfortunately a politician's not going
to say what I'm saying because I guess
it doesn't work probably doesn't work I
don't know why and by the way if you
spoke to cellco you're not going to be
enemies they're actually going to
respect you more they're going to say
finally they got smart they can actually
have more respect you ever see that a
lot of great business people in the room
where when your firm and tough with
somebody you actually develop a better
relationship with them because they
respect you whereas when they make a lot
more money because you're stupid they
don't
respect you you don't have as good a
relationship right now they don't
respect this country they don't respect
our leaders they don't respect what
we're doing and right now this country
is going to be going over a cliff now
just in closing and I think we're going
to take a couple of questions but in
closing I want to say and I think it's
very important I honestly believe that
the upcoming election if not thee is one
of the most important elections ever in
this country's history we have a chance
to be great we have a chance to be an
unbelievable power again and I'm talking
about from an economic standpoint I
don't want China in Afghanistan why is
in China helping with Libya you know who
gets a lot of their oil from Libya not
the United States we get nothing china
why aren't they involved we don't have
the right leaders they don't see it now
if I run and if I win and that's a big
if this country will be great again this
country will be rich again and maybe
most importantly of all this country
will be respected again and thank you
very much it's a great honor to be
thank you very much thank you
mr. Trump thank you very much for those
remarks and / your courtesy we will take
three questions from the audience make
them nice and easy please I'll be happy
to come around I only ask that you give
your name your company affiliation and
then present your question if you
couldn't I'll start here right next to
me thank you as a small businessman grub
business right right business that's
right thank you good negotiator i'll let
him negotiate against china screw those
rudd guys they can negotiate okay I
actually go ahead side I know you said
go ahead thank you I'm as a small
businessman who's been downtown for 53
years and a fourth-generation business
the concern we all have downtown is
we're losing market share the old single
owner businesses are going away as malls
and shopping centers are being built up
what would you do as you see these
downtown suffering what would you have
is a recommendation for us to maybe
change direction and look at it from
another point of view to to be to be
viable again to be healthy again and to
be able to have the next generation do
well well it's a great question and a
lot of towns are having whether it's
walmart or some of the other big ones
and that's probably what you're
referring to their coming in and they
have these massive stores and you know
it's a whole different thing and it's a
changing time and it is changing times
that a lot of towns are knocking them
out I would say this in all fairness if
the economy were good and it's not great
in New Hampshire at all and it's not
great almost anywhere it's you know
where it's good it's a good in
Washington I have this big club in
washington it's doing great you know why
cuz everybody's moving to Washington
because Washington sort of running
everything and they own everything and
that's the exact opposite of what we
want if sigh if this economy were raging
again you would do so great because guys
like me and plenty of others in this
room will be going to your store we're
not going to wherever else it may be but
at this room for everybody everybody so
if we could get this economy going again
if we could get jobs back instead of
having them going to
India and having them go I mean Mexico
there's a place called Newton Iowa where
Maytag was given a huge incentive to
move out of Newton Iowa and that was the
big employer and they moved to Mexico
with our incentive and now Newton is
devastated just absolutely devastated
and this was years ago and they haven't
come back if we could use the right
brain power you would have so much
business and so would everyone else
because you hate to restrict these big
companies from coming in I think even
you would agree to that so and I've seen
plenty of towns do it and they end up
getting hurt in a different way in a
much different way but if we could make
our country strong again economically
we're just teetering along and it's
going to start getting worse and worse
because of what's happening with fuel
and other things and remember this we
have no interest rate i went to a bank
the other day they don't want to if you
have cds they don't give you anything
and you know what if you want to borrow
money today if you're super prime you
can borrow whatever you want and pay
almost nothing problem is if you want to
buy a house they won't give you any
money for a house the people in this
community never take you go to the banks
and it's very very hard don't worry I'm
talking about the big banks I'm not
talking about you your bank is one but
you know they've taken this they've
taken these tremendous subsidies
tremendous subsidies from the government
and now what they're doing is sitting on
them and they're not loaning money for
that and that's one of the big problems
with us now the real problem is what's
going with gasoline in terms of bringing
the world back in terms of bringing our
world back which is the United States
and eventually interest rates are going
to have to go up because the dollar is
being decimated and if you look at your
food costs look at the cost of cotton
that blows away gasoline but if you look
at your food cost if you look at your
clothing costs and if you look at your
gasoline costs it's setting records and
a lot of that is because of the
decimation of the dollar so we have to
get a strong dollar back we have to get
the country going again and you sigh and
everybody else going to make a lot of
money okay thank you we'll take the
second question over here in this corner
and right
right back here playing where's waldo
with you there we go good afternoon mr.
Trump thank you for coming today thank
you my name is Marie mayotte with my
husband and my son we own a small
business across the river in hudson it's
called red brick clothing and before I
ask my question I would like to just say
as the mother of a young naval officer
who did for six month deployments in the
persian gulf between 2003 and 2005 I do
appreciate appreciate your respect for
the job that those young men and women
have done well thank you very much thank
you I do respect it greatly my question
to you is you have made some statements
about not being a nice guy and being
anti establishment and some things like
that to that end if you do enter the
political arena the art of compromise is
something that is kind of important is
that something that you a skill that you
will develop or something that you will
kind of tap into your inner nice guy at
some point just to get the job done okay
it's a very fair question and she's a
comedian first of all I do I hope I am a
nice guy and I say that but I hope I am
a nice guy and I have a lot of great
other things yes go ahead I hope the two
John's go head to head in the final oh
okay I thought she was talking about
candidates I'm trying to figure out
which ones well that's right the
Celebrity Apprentice that's right thank
you it's very funny saying fed do we
have two of them named John okay number
one I hope I am a nice guy but when I
say nice we don't have much room for big
negotiation we've given that up over the
last 10 years 12 years 15 years we have
to do it right and the problem that we
do have is there has been so much copper
let's compromise let's compromise let's
do this let's do that and in the end we
have so much that we have more debt than
ever you add it all up in the history of
the country we have more now than all of
it added up together so we need not
compromise we need smart people and we
need good people and maybe we need lame
duck people maybe people are going to
say you know what we have to do the
right thing for this country and we have
to do it and if it's popular is not
popular whatever it may be that it is to
get this whole thing in order because if
we don't get it in order this country is
going over a cliff and you know they
were comparing it to Greece and they
were comparing us to lots of other
countries that you've been reading about
and I was watching on one of the shows
the other day and they were saying
actually we're in worse shape
proportionately than some of these
countries that we're reading about all
the time and it's true forty cents out
of every dollar goes to pay interest to
China and other places that are making a
fortune on us so we really i think
compromise is a great thing and I've
made plenty of compromises of my life
but I think we're beyond compromise we
have to make we have to do what's right
for the country and if we don't do it
we're not going to have much of a
country left okay thank you it's a great
question thank
mr. Trump I'm over in the corner to your
right shoulder and we'll take the third
and final question okay this afternoon
good afternoon miss Trump hi name is
Mike rancor I work for bae systems as an
engineer in town my question is you've
spoken a lot about getting respect back
for our country abroad but more
importantly here in our community what
are we going to do for new jobs do you
have any novel strategies to develop new
jobs or to grow the account excuse me to
grow the economy well I do actually I do
have a lot of strategies for new jobs we
have to take our manufacturing back from
China and many other places that are
doing it it's real easy you know I
toward I tour two weeks ago I toward New
Hampshire and we had a great time and I
have never seen we had some companies
that I looked at there were absolutely
unbelievable the the level of detail the
the technology the whole thing these are
great manufacturing companies I was so
proud I almost didn't think we had this
anymore in this country we have some
great great people in this country but
when China manipulates their currency so
they take jobs out of New Hampshire in
New England and you look at what's
happened in New England generally where
NAFTA with everyone going down to Mexico
I mean I see plants that are empty and
they're they're thriving over in Mexico
do you think these people want to be in
Mexico the fact is we have to
manufacture our own product we have to
we have to start manufacturing again we
have to by the way get rid of Obamacare
it's a disaster if we don't get rid of
Obamacare I have six friends who are in
business modest sized businesses good
businesses of the 6-2 are going to close
their business another two are thinking
about it because they're saying we can't
afford Obamacare we can't afford the
health care we can't do it and these are
good guys these are guys that employ a
lot of people they have really good
companies midsize companies they're
fantastic people and they're thinking
about closing I never heard them even
mention that word and I've known him for
two of them went to Wharton a couple of
them went to Wharton with me the Wharton
School of funny I never even heard this
we have to get
rid of Obamacare and one other thing I
really think the president is doing this
country a tremendous to service just
like he should have given his birth
certificate years ago instead of making
everyone wait and believe it or not I'm
very proud of what I did getting him to
finally produce it believe me but it's
sort of the same thing we're going
through all these court systems you're
reading about it today they're in
Virginia they're all over the place why
doesn't he allow it just to go to the
Supreme Court you'll save a year and
maybe more than a year and I have I know
people that are going absolutely crazy
with their business because they're
doing this very very very complicated
restructuring on the assumption that
Obamacare happens and if it doesn't
happen they've got to go all the way
back and this is thousands and millions
of businesses in this country why don't
the various legal entities involved
headed by the president in all fairness
why doesn't he let his people go
directly to the Supreme Court win or
lose but at least they'll be certainly
you know business when I talk about
business is a word that's very important
school certainty certainty you need
certainty and at least this way we'll
get a faster decision because ultimately
those people on the Supreme Court are
going to be ruling on Obamacare and they
may approve it and they may not but
wouldn't it be good if we knew what was
going to happen instead of waiting a
year and a half maybe two years and
nobody knows what's going to happen
certainty it's been an honor to be with
you this has been a lot of fun and thank
you all very much thank you thank you
thank you
thank you very much